ich muss auch mal wieder ein bisschen
rein finden in minecraft im stream lief
es eigentlich ganz gut aber heute ist so
einer dieser klassischen aufnahmen
treffer nichts geht
willkommen im neuen jahr mit einer runde
64 erste games heute mit dem max mein
nickname ist timon de oro chipbranche
saints immerhin noch obwohl mein job
richtig voll doch einfach mal lucky
punch
ach ich hab auch keine komplette spiel
weil die gelder wir müssen laufen kann
target wer tagen einlaufen überlebt
überhaupt nicht zurecht kommst das paar
nicht ganz vorn weil ich würde ich
versuche ich sehe ich sehe ich sehe ich
hier auch weiter auf weiterer weiter ich
hab ein bisschen abgehalten
darin kommt ein anbieter der daten
doch ne du [ __ ] oder direkt drei
jetzt kassiert alter der wahl schnell
bedient bronze leggins ist ein eisenrohr
schick schick schick schick schick
schick ja leute es gibt einiges zu
erzählen unter anderem was ich alles so
gemacht haben derzeit keine videos kam
fing alles an mit der klausurphase an
meiner uni da habe ich mir gesagt dass
es jetzt so viel arbeit dass kriege ich
jetzt nicht mehr alles unter einen hut
und dann muss mich für eine sache
entscheiden habe mir gesagt
im hinblick auf meine beine
die zukunft ist vielleicht uni in dem
moment wichtiger da hab ich gesagt jetzt
zwei wochen pause ist auch mal gar nicht
schlecht immer irgendwie an ein jahr
videos gemacht hat ein bisschen durch ab
und zwei wochen wirklich eine pause zu
machen
das schadet einem auch echt nicht dann
kommt mal ein bisschen aus diesem aus
diesem zirkus auch so ein bisschen raus
oder kann man neue perspektive dass das
mal kurz verschnaufen kurz verschoben
ich bin ich im neuen spider danach
wollte ich habe diese hip hop playlist
annährend es kommt ganz einfach punkrock
allerdings auf den links links block
eine bergziege ich muss euch auch
ausruhen bleibt man den brand der weiß
ich dass irgendein kassiert
ich kann ich mal rechts mal rein nein du
bist heute weil ich ich hoffe ich hole
angefressen doch zweimal zwar jetzt sehr
gut so alter action action action
guck mal kurz und gut ich war zum bisher
man so allerdings damit weiter dass wir
in urlaub gefahren sind direkt nachdem
die klausurphase am 23 vorbei war ja ich
habe wirklich bis zum 23 klausuren will
ich in zug gestiegen
zählen sie zur nach sex klare ausfindig
aber hat man eine fast auf ne okay ich
bin auch das vol live wenn sie
zugestimmt und den urlaub gefahren dann
kam aus dem urlaub ein wieder der auch
sehr sehr gut angekommen ist hat mir
auch sehr sehr gut gefällt mich sehr
gefreut hat das gesehen sehr schön es
hat wunderbar das ist etwas ganz anderes
muss zurzeit spielt was solche formen
auflaufen kann
die hälfte geben die hälfte 55 49
aber lasst auch die europa-tochter gehen
wie töller und die mich erwischt alter
ok also wieder einmal gesagt ja ich habe
selbst gesetzt werden
blasien
ich bin von ihr kommt noch von müsst ihr
mich war es noch bis in equipment holen
das ist mir gelungen da hin willst du
brauchst ein bisschen stoff alter wie
verschreckt
jo alter schwede dein beschreibt
zusammen mit dem mit dem mittelalter oh
mein gott da warte ich darauf getroffen
ich hätte ich weitermache nochmals jetzt
allein hier ist in tschechien noch nicht
eingestellt ich sehe meine herzen nicht
alles klar leute ich muss auch mal
wieder ein bisschen rein finden in
minecraft im stream lief es eigentlich
ganz gut aber heute ist so einer dieser
klassischen aufnahme tage wo einfach
nichts geht und mein herz auf meinen
dann muss man halt mal auch mal
durchziehen vow3 etr space einfach ein
genie aber alle prüflinge traten immer
zusammen ja man das ist eine geile idee
wo mein gott wo kommt er her alt aus der
entfernung ärger er nimmt sich aber die
dia chest pain natürlich der altes netz
nicht mehr getroffen
ja wieso muss es mal wieder bisschen
rein finden in minecraft erschafft warte
ja ach so zäh feuerwehr der doppelpunkt
zu schreibers lieblicher dieses mining
da gibt's sofort respekt für und erwarte
ich auch hatte bitte 18 uhr auch wie
beide nö nö aufnahme nicht ewig warten
hier alles klar
aber bei so viel so kassel ex hat jetzt
auch nicht er schreibt ja ja ok als er
glaubte ich dass ich aufnehme leute ihr
wisst es jetzt auch selbst besser
mittlerweile
der einfall zwei pfeile
der bau ist noch da ja okay er schmeckt
ist alles weg helmut schade ist
natürlich durch mit den lecks aber haben
wir die runde noch geholt haben uns in
gaimberg ich ganz gut geschlagen
was macht das natürlich stilecht jiji
so passt alles wenn euch das video
gefallen hat leute das gerne einen
daumen nach oben da und ich habe hier
sehen wir das nahe dass ich noch nicht
so gut in minecraft wieder bin ich muss
mal wieder reinfinden nach ein paar
kurzen pausen jetzt auf jeden fall
werden ab jetzt definitiv wieder
regelmäßig videos kommen so wie es kennt
jeden tag wir sind zum nächsten video
wieder haut rein macht's gut und schau